public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous nous retrouvons pour
une nouvelle saison de l'épreuve de
vérité est toujours bien sûr avec nos
amis et partenaires de l' agence france
presse de radio classique et des échos
alors que les élections sénatoriales
seront un moment clé de la vie politique
à la fin du mois nous recevons ce soir
didier guillaume le président du groupe
socialiste au sénat
bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous trois grandes questions politiques
vous seront posées au cours de cette
émission
d'abord est-ce que vous irez manifester
contre les ordonnances sur le code du
travail
vous avez voté compte vous lirez tout à
l'heure jean-francis pécresse françois
hollande encore utile c'est le mot qu'il
emploie en tout cas pour définir son
avenir politique stéphanie le rouge vous
interrogera à ce sujet à son sujet
également sur le parti socialiste enfin
mickaël szames s abordera donc l'enjeu
des élections sénatoriales vont tes
lettres en fait
une fronde anti macron des élus locaux
mais tout de suite une question
d'actualité
[Musique]
avec bien sûr la catastrophe provoquée
aux antilles par l'ouragan rma et qui
mobilise toute la france a assuré
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron pertes
humaines dégâts considérables et puis ce
spectacle de désolation y at il des
leçon politique à tirer selon vous
didier guillaume de ce type d'événement
climatique sans précédent
d'abord est-ce que nous sommes prêts à
les affronter mais il ya toujours des
leçons à tirer et on peut toujours se
poser la question si nous sommes prêts
pas assez prêt etc
mais la première chose qu'un même
lorsque le roi ces images de désolation
ces destructions de bâtiments publics
c'est la première fois dans notre pays
je pense depuis la guerre qu'une
préfecture et a été rasé n'existe plus
sous les bombes et là c'est un ouragan
cet ouragan c'est le plus fort ouragan
depuis que les satellites existe qui a
été constaté c'est absolument terrible
et moi d'abord genre de l'empathie de la
sympathie de la solidarité c'est pas un
lieu commun de dire ça pour les
habitants de des antilles en général et
plus particulièrement de cerval
saint-barthélemy et de saint-martin et
puis une pensée pour nos deux amis
guillaume arnel et michel magras ce
qu'ils sont les sénateurs de saint
martin et de saint barthélémy et qui
aujourd'hui sont dans une situation
terrible anthologie méritait bien sûr
oui oui mais une pensée aussi pour tous
nos amis antillais qui habite à paris
qui habite en france parce que ce qui se
passe là ce qu'elles vivent là bas est
absolument incroyable extraordinaire au
sens de pas ordinaire
alors le président de la république le
premier ministre les ministres le
gouvernement a mis tout ce qui est en
oeuvre pour la solidarité pour les
secours pour demain à la réfection c est
bien sûr que ça ne fait que commencer
parce que je ne sais pas s'ils peuvent
arriver sur les îles comment ils
pourront le faire et je pense que
l'heure n'est pas de savoir si ac a été
fait une souci nous sommes prêts il faut
d'abord réparer soigner guérir
reconstruire donc je suis sûr à mon sens
je ne suis ni technicienne et
climatologues c'est que le réchauffement
climatique
notre planète nous n'avons qu'une ça a
été dit à la conférence de paris et dans
ce cadre là il faut en vraiment en
prendre soin il faut que les grandes
puissances notamment les états unis
d'amérique qui risquent d'être touchés à
miami beach dans les heures qui viennent
comprennent qu'on ne peut pas faire
n'importe quoi et d'ailleurs la loi
nouvelle loi de transition énergétique
devra mettre des choses très fortes
parce que aujourd'hui l'enjeu
environnemental
l'enjeu de protection de la planète et
de ses habitants que soient les animaux
sur la faune la flore où les humains est
quelque chose d'essentiel
alors sans doute que le chef de l'état
pensait à donald trump lorsqu'il a
évoqué aujourd'hui à athènes ce qui
manque d'esprit de conséquence un
peut-être pour justement ne pas tirer
les leçons politiques de ces événements
qui se multiplient sur la planète même
si des légumes il faut dire que des
spécialistes ne se prononce pas encore
il y à un débat sur le savent bien sûr
le lien entre la fréquence l'intensité
de ses cyclones et puis les dérèglements
qui mattei clal la preuve n'est pas
encore apporté certains même 10 kg pour
y avoir moins de cyclones à l'avenir
enfin moi je n'en sais rien tout ce que
je sais c'est que là il ya un cyclone
terrible et évitons j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure sur une autre radio une autre
chaîne des début de polémique
on en vint polémique est en tous les cas
le chef de l'état a bien sûr a raison
d'y aller mais évidemment plein
gouvernement est mobilisé comme tout
gouvernement l'aurait fait ça y'a pas de
ya pas de problème et je pense que c'est
très important pour deux raisons pour
montrer à vos concitoyens ultramarins
que ce ne sont pas des souffrances et
qu'ils sont comme les autres que ça se
passe dans le var une inondation que ça
se passe ailleurs en france ou aux
antilles c'est la même chose ce sont des
français sont nos concitoyens est-ce que
les champs justement d'appartenir à la
france contrairement à d'autres villes
alentour qui elles sont indépendantes et
est souvent démuni solidarité ça bien
sûr que le fait qu'il soit français que
ce soit sur des îles françaises va
sûrement les aider mais à ce niveau-là
de dégâts il n'ya pas d'appartenance et
untel untel c'est la solidarité mondiale
elle est à l'oeuvre
elle est à l'oeuvre et elle doit avancer
vite il faut réparer il faut guérir la
suite de l'épreuve de vérité avec donc
jean francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique
éditorialiste aux échos
bonsoir jean francis michel bonsoir
didier guillaume à la loi et vous
interroger sur une notre actualitté
peut-être certainement beaucoup beaucoup
moins tragique mais d'une actualité
aussi social en france
est-ce que vous irez manifester le 12
septembre contre la loi de réforme du
code du travail
non je n'irai pas manifester je pense
que ce n'est pas ma place d'y aller le
parti socialiste a essayé de donner des
consignes pour faire en sorte que
solidarité mais pas manifestations mais
chacun doit y aller en q2 en fonction de
ce qu'il compte faire
en ce qui me concerne moi je pense que
les socialistes font ce qu'ils veulent
donc moi je n'irai pas à pas les
vêtements d'un benoît hamon par exemple
qui lui a dit qu'il irait mais ça fait
bien partie de la candidate a fait bien
partie des lignes politiques et qui
traverse tous les partis dans notre pays
mais qui traverse le parti socialiste
particulièrement depuis vienne avoir
l'élection présidentielle avec les
frondeurs et cetera aujourd'hui ce que
nous devons faire c'est simple c'est que
les socialistes redéfini ce qu'ils sont
faut arrêter de dire que la gauche est
morte que les idées socialistes sont
mortes non mais leur incarnation
aujourd'hui en france elle est morte
on va en parler d'un instant on va
rester sur les réformes les grandes
regus en langue c'est très important
parce que ce qui se passe là c'est la
ligne de fracture entre les socialistes
est-ce que l'on court après et jean luc
mélenchon ou pas est-ce que l'on court
après les insoumis ou pas ou est ce que
nous sommes des socios réformistes des
sociaux démocrates des progressistes qui
veulent avancer
emmanuel macron a été élu que ça plaise
ou que ça plaise pas il a été élu il a
annoncé dans sa campagne qu'il ferait
ses ordonnances qu'il réformerait le
code du travail
il l'a fait aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
faut aller plus loin nous les
socialistes doivent pas être ceux qui
sont contre les réformes mais ce qui
améliore les réformes dans un sens de
plus de justice sociale et d'équité
est ce que à ce sujet vous condamner les
déclarations très dures de martine aubry
hier qui parle d'une régression sociale
très importante qui dit avec cette
réforme cette loi on revient 50 ans en
arrière est ce que vous trouvez que
celle va beaucoup trop loin
moi je ne paniquons d'année ni dire quoi
que ce soit sur sur martine aubry
mais je pense qu'elle se trompe dans son
analyse je pense que cette loi n'est pas
une régression de 50 ans en arrière
cette loi ne réglera pas tout cette loi
ne fera pas créer des milliers d'emplois
dans l'est dans les semaines qui
viennent mais cette loi a au moins
l'avantagé d'avoir été annoncé pendant
la campagne des élections
présidentielles et d'être quelque chose
qui va se mettre en application
regardons il ya eu un débat vous avez
voté contre et je vais même pas le genre
y venir habilitations oui j'ai voté
contre au sénat mais vous y entendez le
texte non non avec l'ensemble du groupe
socialiste parce que pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que la méthode me
semble-t-il aurait pu être beaucoup plus
ouverte
les parlementaires n'ont pas eu assez de
assez d'informations je salue dans cette
loi quelque chose d'essentiel
c'est le dialogue social les syndicats
qui ont participé au groupe de travail
sur le dialogue ont obtenu des choses et
notamment sur le sur des accords de
branche il y à des avancées dans cette
réforme cette réforme n'a pas été
décriée comme on nous on nous disait
elle a été acceptée plus ou moins bon
gré moi je regrette une fois de plus
cette étude du medef et de monsieur
gattaz qui dit ce n'est qu'un début ça
ne va pas assez loin il faut que ma
croûte continue moi ce qu'il faut c'est
que
gattaz et ses amis créent des emplois de
demander toujours plus toujours plus
toujours plus et ce qu'ils demandent
c'est plus pour eux et moins pour les
salariés et moi ce que je souhaite et ce
que je constate dans cette loi c'est
qu'il ya des choses qui vont dans le bon
sens je cite il dialogue social je cite
et les accords de branche dont on
craignait qu'ils les difficultés ça va
dans le bon sens la transformation du
camp de pénibilité un compte de
prévention moi je trouve que c'est
quelque chose de bien je mets un bémol
sur les fameux critères les six cantons
été acceptée et les cadres qui ont été
enlevés notamment le la pénibilité sur
la pénibilité mais je veux simplement
dire que ce n'était pas applicable avec
l'art l'état donc pas le cas avant ça
avance oui mais ça fait partie de la loi
le code du travail
ce n'est pas à côté de choses et lambaye
que l'on m'a mais comme ça code du
travail qui nous attend à une sens et
moi je pense que ce qui ne va pas dans
le bon sens et qui manque un peu de
sécurité dans la flexisécurité c'est à
dire et à dire que la flexibilité
pourquoi pas la sécurité pour nos
concitoyens pour les salariés il la faut
un peu plus j'attends de voir comment
les choses se passeront moi je n'ai pas
de crainte à priori sur les négociations
dans les entreprises mais il faut il
faut vraiment que les syndicats puissent
être associés que les délégués du
personnel puissent avoir leurs mots leur
mot à dire et ça pour l'instant ce n'est
pas encore assez ce n'est pas encore
assez fait donc cette loi pour moi elle
est mitigé je ne l'achète pas comme ça
aux orties à la poubelle comme certains
mais je n'en fais pas non plus l'alpha
et l'oméga de la une forme de filiation
avec une fois que vous avez soutenu
quand vous étiez quand la majorité était
enfin comme lors de la précédente
majorité qui était la vôtre plutôt je
peux être humain qui était la loi elle
comme riz et je viens une filiation
entre elles que bree et mais évidemment
il y avait même une filiation de la loi
mc ren lorsqu'il était ministre de
l'économie et macron président de la
république notamment sur les sur les
prud'hommes sur les prud'hommes les
choses ont été mal acceptée mal
comprises parfois les zélés
les efforts qui ont été faits et la
négociation ont amené plus de choses
pour les salariés voyons mais en même
temps je vois bien qu'en disant cela je
pense que les français ne s'y
reconnaissent pas parce que mal
expliquée par le gouvernement est mal
expliquée par ceux qui soutiennent
vraiment le gouvernement fait que les
français s'interrogent donc il faudra
voir comment les choses comment les
choses avancent mais un point très
positif quand même je veux il insisté
c'est la négociation et le travail
syndicats madame pénicaud la ministre on
peut lui reprocher ce que l'on veut mais
elle a mis en place une négociation avec
son cabinet des dizaines et des dizaines
et des dizaines d'heures qui fait que
les syndicalistes savait que cette loi
allait arriver
ils ont pu négocier et ceux qui se sont
atteints de lam et adaptable en valeur
de leurs méthodes et la ville très
positif parce que vous alternez là les
critiques et puis les bons points nombre
est globalement c'est bon mais moi je
regarde les choses telles qu'elles sont
rendus aliment très haut jeudi ya des
points qui ne me plaisent pas alors j'ai
des points qui vont dans le dans le bon
sens nous verrons nous verrons au
marchand rien d'autre et forme quand ils
sont lancés un ya les régimes spéciaux
et c'est là projet de réforme du régime
spécial de la sncf je crois qu'on va on
va écouter justement ce matin sur public
sénat philippe martinez de leader de la
cgt qui réagit c'est donc à cette
nouvelle réforme ait effectivement
annoncé par emmanuel macron lui même
donc désendetter la sncf qui en a bien
besoin contre certaines modifications
notamment le statut des cheminots et
leurs fameuses retraites
on présente les régimes spéciaux comme
quelqu'un encore un privilège un
privilège et que ce serait l'ensemble
des français qui paieraient pour mes
petits doigts et vous savez très bien
que le régime de la dsa des salariés de
la sncf est un régime particulier qui
n'a rien à voir qui n'a rien à voir avec
le régime mais l'ensemble des citoyens
gym est excédentaire est excédentaire et
je pense que ça intéresse beaucoup leur
au gouvernement de récupérer
l'excédent de ce régime pour la gérer
dans un autre registre vous reconnaissez
pas si vide le régime spécial
c'est un risque là aussi on essaie de
faire passer les cheminots pour des
privilégiés
c'est un faux problème bah c'est un faux
problème dit-il en tous les cas il est
il est en contradiction avec la cour des
comptes sains qui qui dénonce ce régime
spécial en rappelant que l'état met plus
de 3 milliards
tous les ans pour boucler le déficit
bien une chose qui est sûre c'est que
les cheminots ne sont pas comme le dit
fort justement filet martinez ce ne sont
pas des privilégiés
bon il faut arrêter avec le bouc
émissaire des uns et des autres moi je
n'accepte pas ça les cheminots sont des
gens qui travaillent dur qui font leur
travail dans un beau métier qu'il faut
un métier quelques parts service public
même si le statut de la sncf avance et
on est bien content que les trains
arrivent à l'heure il peut y avoir des
histoires des bugs etc monde est bien
content d'avoir des contrôleurs et bien
contraint d'être accompagné par contre
moi je pense que là encore emmanuel
macron est élu pour bouger pour réformer
si si tout était allé bien je pense pas
que macro aurait été élu et peut-être
même que d'autres puissent représenter
les deux anciens présidents de la
république qu'ils ont été ils n'ont pas
pu se représenter aussi et donc réformer
les retraites et notamment réformer les
retraites beitia spéciales comme celles
de la sncf
moi je n'accepterai pas qu'on dise c'est
pour un problème de déficit de s de la
sncf
c'est tout simplement pour faire en
sorte que les françaises et les français
soient sur un pied d'égalité
il faudra voir là encore la méthode
comment les choses se passeront je le
dis tranquillement ça ne me choque pas
ça a été annoncé dans la campagne
électorale
ça ne me choque pas que l'on regarde les
régimes spécifiques faut voir comment
c'est fait ça ne peut pas être fait de
façon brutale ça peut pas être fait en
tournant le dos aux as et un sound
avantages acquis mais il faut avancer il
faut avancer
emmanuel macron a été élu pour pour
faire cela et puis les français jugeront
après il a raison mais je dis pas si la
raison avait on vous pose là il a bien
raison où il à moi je suis favorable à
ce que l'on met sur un même pied
d'égalité les retraites des fractures
dont qu'il arrête
oui mais là ça veut dire aussi ça
implique aussi qu'il n'y aurait plus
d'âge de départ anticipé à la retraite
pour les conducteurs vous êtes savoir à
plat ça mais il va y avoir un débat
parlementaire nous verrons les choses
mais quand on dit réforme des régimes
spécifiques c'est qu'il faut que tous
les français partent à la avec le même
nombre d'annuités partent à la retraite
quasiment avec le même âge a plus
pauvres en deux problèmes du privé du
public
tout cela doit se faire dans un débat
plutôt long et dans la concertation si
j'ai bien compris c'est un est un débat
qui aidera sur la table année prochaine
ou ou celle d'après ou là ou en 2018
bref nous regarderons ça tranquillement
dans l'intérêt de la france certes parce
qu'il faut que la france se modernise la
france réussit mais sans oublier parce
que parfois d'attendre un peu trop
oublié les françaises et des français
alors moi je voulais savoir ce que vous
pensiez aussi d'une autre réforme c'est
cette réforme c'est ce projet de réforme
qui va consister à baisser les
cotisations maladie et chômage des
salariés pour les transférer vers la csg
donc cotisation à base plus large qui
touche plus de gens et qui permettra de
rendre du pouvoir d'achat aux salariés
est ce que c'est une bonne réforme
je pense que il ya une chose qui était
importante dans ce que dit le président
de la république c'est le pouvoir
d'achat après on va le voir à l'oeuvre
on va voir comment ça se passe et je
vous dirai de crainte que j'aime et
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat est
indispensable quand quelqu'un gagne 1500
euros 2000 euros ils peuvent pas son
argent ils le dépensent quand quelqu'un
guen 100 milles qu'ils en gagnent 100
mille neuf cent cinquante mille il va
pas le dépasser parce que toute façon on
peut pas le faire et lui il le place où
ils optimisent donc l'augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat est quelque chose de
très important ça va être fait
apparemment à plusieurs niveaux la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation que
je considère moi comme une très bonne
mesure pour les français qui la paye
mais avec une difficulté pour les
communes qui perçoivent l'argent que
cette taxe d'habitation
nous allons donc regarder comment d'un
côté les bénéficiaires pourront être
bénéficiaire en ne payant plus
d'habitations et c'est pour moi une très
bonne mesure mais de l'autre côté que ça
ne pénalise pas les communes
c'est toujours comme cela moi j'essaie
d'être le plus objectif possible
l'augmentation de la csg c'est dans
l'est dans le programme des socialistes
depuis des décennies dont je peux pas y
être opposé mais je suis opposé à
l'augmentation de la csg pour les
retraités parce que ça peut pas être ça
il peut pas y avoir meilleur que cette
nouvelle annonce qui aura lieu ces mots
des sacs tant mieux s'il est en tout cas
moi je ne serai pas favorable je ne suis
pas dans sa réponse rapide
il semble que le gouvernement ait
confirmé aux collectivités locales que
les 13 milliards d'euros d'économies qui
leur demanderait sur le quinquennat
serait en fait sur l'évolution prévu ces
dépenses et que donc en réalité il n'y
aura pas de baisse nette de leurs
dépenses
est ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
saluer ce soir mieux en mieux oui parce
que les collectivités locales ont
l'habitude de faire des efforts elle
gère globalement bien à 90 ou 95 98 % je
n'en sais rien elles ont fait des
efforts sous le précédent quinquennat
françois hollande a demandé à donner à
demander des baisses pour les
collectivités à baisser les dotations en
nombre des médias comme comme beaucoup
mais cette mesure est une bonne mesure
tel qu'annoncé au départ les
collectivités locales ne s'en serait pas
sortie ski à ce que vient d'annoncer le
gouvernement ou le président de la
république là il y à quelques heures va
dans le bon sens très bien merci
beaucoup
jean-francis nous allons m'a dit on va
cueillir stéphanie le rouge de l' agence
france presse pour la deuxième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité on continue de
parler du parti socialiste vous étiez
très désireux d'emblée d'en parler des
diego sous un angle politique avec cette
question françois hollande encore utile
c'est en tous les cas ce qu'il prétend
écoutons ces propos lors de
l'installation de sa fondation
aujourd'hui je suis dans la phase de
lancement de cette fondation
je ne vais pas donc que faire des
commentaires qui altéreraient l'idée
même que je me fais de cette fondation
puisque je veux lui donner toute sa
portée mais lorsque je considérais qu'il
ya des commentaires à faire ou des
lotions attirer ou des propositions à
faire
je prendrai la parole et ce sera un
moment qui devra être particulièrement
bien choisi là aussi pour qu'il puisse
être utile à la france et où je pourrai
m'exprimer longuement alors françois
hollande prendra la parole quand il
jugera ça utile est ce que ce sera utile
selon vous quelle prenne la parole ou
est-ce que le silence de l'ancien chef
de l'état ne serait pas préférable à la
france et au ps mais ils valéry giscard
d'estaing
après 1981 a été candidat à des
élections il a été député il était
président de la région auvergne il a
parlé nicholas ayache chirac c'est un
peu à part par un bord à ces difficultés
physiques mais nicolas sarkozy et partie
a été battue puis s'est remis à parler
puis je crois même qu'il a été candidat
pour être président de son parti et puis
candidat à la primaire là on parle
vérité jour par l'ancien président qui
n'a pas été en mesure de se représenter
oui d'accord mais enfin il a d'autres
qui sont représentées qui ont été battus
donc à l'arrivée ils sont pas élus mais
on gagne on perd m
et puis françois hollande est là moi je
crois que françois hollande ferait ce
qu'il a ce qu'il a à faire
moi j'ai entendu tout un tas de
commentaires oui c'est très bien qu'il
intervienne
non il faut absolument pas on n'a pas
besoin de lui mais c'est pas ça le sujet
est ce que françois hollande dans ce
qu'il dira dira des choses qui seront
utiles au pays
c'est plutôt ce que je pense donc tant
mieux tant mieux est-ce qu'il a encore
un avenir en politique ce qu'il se voit
un avenir en politique qu'est ce que
vous vous souhaitez qu'il en est un
est-ce que hollande 2022 c'est crédible
à quoi ces bibles nous sommes nous
sommes en septembre 2017
trois mois après l'élection
présidentielle on n'a pas commencé dès
2017 à savoir qui va se présenter en
2022 que ça n'aurait aucun sens la
question de savoir et de savoir si
françois hollande dans le débat peut
amener des choses positives des
réflexions évidemment est-ce qu'il va
redevenir un acteur politique de premier
plan
je crois qu'il a même dit n'encaisse que
vous souhaitez je n'en sais rien vous
souhaitez mais vous êtes proche de lui
et vous appelle de temps en temps comme
il appelle tous les normes ex-socialiste
non mais merci à la caisse merci pour
les castings pour les classiques
classique mais il fera ce que ce que la
même
il fera ce que bon lui semblera
aujourd'hui le retour de françois
hollande n'est pas l'actualité sais pas
ce que souhaitent les français et demain
donc on verra ce qui se passera demain
en fonction de l'évolution ce que vous
souhaitez vous pas comment mais moi je
n'ai pas à souhaiter le retour françois
hollande ou pas le retour je vois pas
d'ailleurs comment ils reviendraient
pour faire quoi et cetera il est engagé
dans sa dans sa fondation il va prendre
la parole à plusieurs reprises il
l'apprendra plus honda rcv c'est pas
c'est pas en disant je vais revenir et
je vais intervenir que ça va
révolutionner les choses raison de
mettre en garde les manuels macron sur
les sacrifices
demandez aux français c'était une bonne
intervention ça son intervention était
bonne je pense que comme président de la
république sortant
il est intervenu peut être un peu vite
mais ces mises en garde était réel
françois hollande reçoit beaucoup on
certains pensent qu'il continue de tirer
un petit peu les ficelles à solférino
est ce que est ce que vous pensez que
c'est une bonne chose qu'il soit comme
ça influent encore dans les destinées du
parti social il ne tire pas les ficelles
de solférino françois hollande reçoit il
a dit qu'il n'arrêtait pas la politique
qu'il voulait quand tu dans la politique
tout le monde le connaît c'est son adn
il
il est il aime cela tant mieux et là sa
fondation il reçoit des responsables
politiques des socialistes notamment jeu
peut-être ceux qui sont plus proches de
lui ou d'autres mais il ne tire pas les
ficelles du congrès effacé par françois
hollande qui va s'occuper de la
recomposition de la restructuration du
parti socialiste de ce que sera le ps
demain kinés des choses à dire oui mais
je pense que aujourd'hui
et là je le dis franchement ceux qui
devront prendre les rênes du parti
socialiste
c'est ce qu'ils devront incarner
l'avenir donc une génération plus jeune
je le crois vraiment moi je fais partie
déjà de ceux qui sont trop vieux pour
faire cela pour repartir à la
reconstruction pour les 10 ans qui
viennent c'est pas entre 60 70 ans 65
ans que l'on fait ça que l'on puisse
servir les caciques où les sages tant
mieux pourquoi pas si je peux aider par
rapport à ma modeste expérience mais
aujourd'hui c'est aux cadres à de
prendre dans leur galerie de prendre et
nous donner je vais pas donner aussi des
nouveaux leaderships et d'un parti qui
est aujourd'hui complètement inaudible
est en crise et ont valeur qui
aujourd'hui personne à mon sens
aujourd'hui personne n'est aujourd'hui
personne est en capacité d'incarner le
leadership qui soit reconnu par tous
aujourd'hui il n'y en a pas mais enfin
rendez vous compte ce qui s'est passé au
parti socialiste 6% à la l'élection
présidentielle une claque monumentale
aux législatives voilà donc aujourd'hui
il faut prendre le temps d'hier qui est
chef du parti qui va c'est beaucoup trop
tôt il faut reconstruire
je pense que la gauche n'est pas morte
je pense que les idées
sociales-démocrates prouve
6 euro péenne laïque républicaine
écologiste ne sont pas morts est ce que
vous trouvez que la reconstruction est
sur de bons rails avec cette direction
collégiale provisoire qui est
pléthorique et la première décision qui
en est sorti c'est de faire des ateliers
la refondation est aussi de réformer les
statuts du ps
est-ce que ça c'est une bonne chose font
ce qu'ils peuvent
c'est pas facile et travailler dans une
direction collégiale à 26 personnes
c'est sûrement pas évident vous savez là
l'écrasement l'explosion ça va toujours
très vite la décomposition est ultra
rapide mais la recomposition la
reconstruction prendra beaucoup de temps
après l'échec de 1969 où notre candidat
défait 5 % gaston defferre
ce n'est qu'en 1971 et du coup fait deux
ans après que que françois mitterrand a
reconstruit un parti 2010 8e bonne date
où c'est trop tôt certains ont dit c'est
trop tôt il faut à anono moi je pense
pas du tout qu'il soit trop tôt il faut
maintenant de décider ce que doit faire
le parti socialiste pose années qui
viennent parce qu'il y aura des
élections municipales et on aura une
stratégie
il va falloir définir des choses assez
clair qu'elle est notre ligne politique
dont nos stratégies idéologique
quelle est notre stratégie d'alliance et
puis qu'est sur quel sur quels fonds
politiques nous nous travaillons le
parti socialiste depuis 2005 depuis le
référendum sur l'europe notamment est
assez divisés il faut le cadrer on a
fait des congrès le congrès de poitiers
a eu lieu il ya eu un vote
il ya une motion majoritaire et une
minoritaire mais les minoritaires n'ont
pas accepté la majorité
aujourd'hui c'est le collège
la ligne du parti actuellement c'est
d'être dans l'opposition constructive
celle site vous vous êtes plutôt dans la
participation vigilante
vers quoi ça doit aller plutôt vers moi
en tout cas je participerai dans la
reconstruction du parti socialiste avec
un certain nombre de mes amis à faire en
sorte que le parti socialiste ne soit
pas dans l'opposition frontale en
faisant communiquer sur communiqué
contre tous mais en étant plutôt
vigilant parce qu'il faut quand la
recrue oui parce qu'il faut que la
france réussisse d'accord et il faut que
macro réussi par rapport à lui mais donc
moi je suis un oui j'ai la position vous
convient non non je pense moi la ligne
de position celle du parti je n'ai rien
à redire mais pour le prochain congrès
je pense que le parti socialiste doit
pas être dans l'opposition totale mais
doit être plutôt dans l'accompagnement
vigilant dans ya des choses qui vont pas
et des choses qui vont tranquillement
parce que quand on passe son temps à
s'opposer
eh bien on a du mal à prêt à proposer et
les socialistes contrairement à d'autres
contrairement à d'autres partis
d'extrême gauche l'autre ne sont pas là
pour être dans la rue ne sont pas là
pour être contre tout sur la pour
accéder à nouveau pouvoir un jour donc
avoir un projet politique fort qui peut
rassembler une majorité donc certains de
vos amis et camarades du parti
socialiste qui lorgne du côté de
jean-luc mélenchon pour d'éventuelles
alliances demain ont tort et ce qu'ils
font courir un risque aux parties ah
mais non mais je ne m'étendrai pas
qu'ils ont tort margossian or je dis
simplement qu'il ya deux lignes dans le
vrai que pensez vous de ce fait je
regarde du côté jean luc mélenchon moi
je pense qu'il ne faut pas regarder il
ne faut pas courir après jean-luc mais
non marchandes le danger à skis courts
lors tout court a toujours plus vite que
nous parce que nous ne sommes pas sur la
même base politique et idéologique sur
l'europe sur sur la france sur le social
nous nous sommes des réformistes nous
voulons avancer
nous voulons transformer la société nous
ne sommes pas dans la radicalité et je
ne pense pas que ce soit la ligne que
nous dans laquelle nous devons aller
vous aviez le congrès dira ce qu'il en
dise qu'il devra dire à mon pad jean luc
mélenchon vous l'avez entendu il le
répète ils misent en fait sur une fin
anticipée du quinquennat d'emmanuel
manque macron avec des élections donc et
puis son accession au pouvoir qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ce qui ressemble à
un pari sinon il est une forme de
pression qu'en pensez vous comme est
inacceptable d'entendre ça fasse
inacceptable a droit de le dire mais
mais moi ça me choque terriblement il
est élu depuis trente ou quarante ans il
a exercé tous les postes a été le plus
jeune plus jeune sénateur est offert
dégager tout le monde ait eu des
élections présidentielle et des
élections législatives
on peut se dire il ya pas eu assez de
votants peut-être mais la démocratie a
toujours raison parce que quand on met
en cause la démocratie alors c'est vers
un autre système qu'on peut se tourner
et on voit ce qui s'est passé dans le
pays qu'il aime beaucoup au venezuela
bon donc du coup benoît hamon qui va
manifester avec lui je mets ça vous
résultat mais ça ne me sert pas nous ne
sommes pas sur la même élite were
politique non nous ne sommes pas sur la
même ligne politique
c'est pour ça que j'appelle à une
clarification politique une
clarification ni démagogique et une
clarification stratégique doit venir sur
jean luc mélenchon il dit aussi que
emmanuel macron n'a pas reçu mandat du
peuple pour le programme de réformes
qu'il met à l'oeuvre il dit cela oui
mais j'ai raison des circonstances du
second tour de la présidentielle mais
bien sûr il avoue choc vous trouvez ça
inacceptable oui parce que et emmanuel
mac on en pense que l'on en veut on est
d'accord ou pas d'accord il a été élu
démocratiquement au deuxième tour face à
l'extrême droite
il ya donc des gens qui ont voté pour
lui au deuxième tour qui n'était pas fou
qu'il n'était pas favorable qui voulait
vite et l'extrême droite mais aussi des
gens qui ont pris leur responsabilité
contrairement à jean luc mélenchon et
qui on a beau appeler à voter clairement
pour macron pour battre l'extrême droite
et lui ne l'a pas fait donc ya pas de
leçon de démocratie à à donner dans ce
dans ce cadre la dernière question
peut-être stéphanie encore sur le parti
socialiste en fait dit tout à l'heure
qu'il faudra du temps pour reconstruire
le ps or on en parlait jean luc
mélenchon pendant ce temps déroule
est ce que est ce que le
jean luc mélenchon et sa france a soumis
sont devenus les premiers opposants à
emmanuel macron et ce qu'ils prennent
trop d'espacé à gauche les français
aujourd'hui j'ai lu les enquêtes
considère que mais dans le champ et le
principal opposant à emmanuel macron je
préfère soit mélenchon et le pen 1 si je
puis dire mais c'est pas le sujet on en
n'est pas là pour courir après mélenchon
à nous de nous reconstruire est ce qui
prend trop d'espacé on verra bien vous
savez tout ça la démocratie va tourner
il ya cinq ans nous ont fait 3 mois
il reste donc quatre ans et neuf mois on
va voir comment les choses évoluent le
travail démocratique se passe au
parlement bien sûr qu'il faut écouter la
rue et les réseaux sociaux
évidemment plus droit de grève et et
constitutionnelles et que les gens vont
manifester et moi je respecte les gens
qui vont aller manifester par leurs
convictions je ne voudrais pas que
certains en fassent une opération
politique ou politicienne à des fins
personnelles mais le droit de grève
gilles arrêter de manifester j'ai rien à
dire je n'ai rien à dire là-dessus mais
demain le parti socialiste ne doit pas
être le principal opposant à maquereau
le parti socialiste ou être le principal
acteur politique qui veut transformer la
société
voilà le programme pour les mois et les
années qui viennent merci stéphanie
dernière partie des priorités avec
michaël szames s de public sénat qui
nous rejoint maintenant et nous allons
parler de l'enjeu des élections
sénatoriales à la fin du mois
on sort mais quel bon sens mais chez
incendies des clients soit je veux
savoir si les élections sénatoriales qui
arrivent vont se transformer en une
fronde contre emmanuel macron salue les
élections sénatoriales bien malin celui
qui peut dire comment elles se passent
chaque fois un jeu atypique une élection
atypique parce que c'est un mode de
scrutin atypique avec un corps électoral
reste que les annonces qui ont été
faites ces derniers temps les annonces
économiques notamment robert et détaillé
si vous le voulez mais ne passe que vous
servir finalement oui bien sûr moi je
pense que le gouvernement et la
république un march a commis des erreurs
en faisant ces annonces la baisse
unilatérale de 5 euros pour l'apl
ce n'est pas une bonne chose même si les
choses peuvent être discutés ce n'est
pas une bonne chose
la baisse des notations ce n'est pas une
bonne chose c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement à rectifier le tir et puis
franchement la suppression des contrats
aidés la goutte d'eau c'est la goutte
d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
parce que nous le disions au début de
notre entretien les maires les élus sont
prêts à beaucoup de sacrifices pour pas
pour eux mêmes c'est pas le sujet pour
le budget de la commune et ont fait
beaucoup et aujourd'hui contrairement à
l'état y'a pas un budget communal en
déficit et le travail a été fait mais à
des moments et des arguments qui ne sont
pas acceptables et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'espère que comme pour les
dotations le gouvernement regardera
différemment les contrats aidés
bien sûr qu'il vaut mieux un cdi un
contrat un emploi de fonctionnaire un
emploi à durée déterminée à un contrat
aidé enfin en vidant ne vit pas dans le
même monde touche aux emplois aidés
comment il ne fallait pas toucher aux
emplois aidés c'est une erreur que les
choses évoluent que là également le
mouvement à la baisse avait été
enclenché sous le précédent quinquennat
mouvement à la baisse n'est pas éteinte
le président
oui mais la question n'est pas là oui
mais je vais vous répondre très
tranquillement les contrats les contrats
aidés
je vous le disais à l'instant il vaut
mieux qu'ils soient remplacés par des
contrats à durée indéterminée ou par des
postes de fonctionnaires évidemment on
sait que ceux qui ont des contrats aidés
ne trouve pas tous des emplois après
pourquoi parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de
ces vérités sur le manque de formation
de ces contrats et des mois dans une
ville que je connais bien la mienne est
bien la plupart de ceux qui sont en
contrat aidé trouve des forts du travail
après parce que le maire de la ville
fait un effort terrible sur la formation
que le budget demande à ce que l'on
réduise un peu peut-être lassé
suppression des contrats aidés ça ne va
pas et ça ne peut pas être fait de façon
brutale
on ne peut pas faire ça c'est qu'on
appelait à c'est très brutal en plein
été pour dire à la rentrée scolaire
eh bien il manquera d manquera des
candidats un manque de considération
pour les collectivités territoires je ne
crois pas qu'il ya un manque de
considération emmanuel macron est venu
au sénat pour lancer les états généraux
a discuté oui oui oui mais tout le monde
et place pour labourer mais après boom
je pense que c'est une erreur parce que
c'est un manque de considération je
pensais qu'une erreur à l'on parle de
fronde anti macro et affront quand même
qui va qui réunit la gauche
et puis la droite puisque françois
baroin certes président consensuel de
l'association des maires de france est
également monté au créneau hier pour
dénoncer ce coup sur la tête
halte au feu et que nous demandons au
gouvernement de reprendre ou d'aller
faire un collectif budgétaire avant même
la discussion de la loi de finances
techniquement c'est possible et
d'amendés immédiatement pour que la
totalité des emplois c'est à dire la
parole de l'état soient respectés on
suit une discussion plus tard lorsque la
croissance soit revenu
ce qui a le plus efficace pour les uns
pour les autres c'est autre chose mais
là on l'état ce n'est pas tenable ça
n'est pas acceptable c'est dangereux
pour les personnes qui sont concernées
et c'est dangereux aussi pour la qualité
des services publics sur la totalité des
territoires de notre pays
des propos que vous pourriez tenir
également gérer la rajouter mais
pourtant ça n'est pas quand même
paradoxal de voir aujourd'hui
heller parler de la même voix que les
insoumis que le parti socialiste martine
aubry
comment une fronde mais non pourquoi
mais pourquoi l'association des maires
de fans déjà parce que les candidats
aient l'air qui étaient tous partants
pour la présidentielle voulait aussi
coupé le robinet des mélangeurs un pays
ruiné je vais venir je vais venir mais
l'association des maires de france est
une association qui est paritaire est
elle même nombre d'élus de droite et de
gauche au bureau ils ne tiennent pas
compte de la réalité politique c'est la
règle de base
bon ce que vient de dire françois baroin
s'en va c'est trop brutale or at il faut
que ces patients moratoire j'aimais
voulu des moratoires sous le précédent
quinquennat je vais pas en demander à
maintenant mais enfin vous pourriez qui
est une évoqué de l'évoquer une
évolution que demain on puisse parler de
ce débat tout remettre à plat de ses
sujets ok mais ce qui fait quand même
doucement rire c'est que sont les mêmes
qui voulait supprimer 500 mille cinq
cent mille postes de fonctionnaires qui
voulait supprimer tous les contrats
aidés qui pensaient que des contrats
aidés c'était c'était nul et non avenu
c'était pas des vrais emplois qui disent
maintenant faut les garder il vaut mieux
essayer c'est ce que modestement
j'essaye de toujours garder la même
ligne allait faire de démagogie
eh bien nous verrons ce qu'il faudra
pour les élections sénatoriales et ma
question à ce que je pense je pense que
je sais pas si c'est une fronde anti
macron les élections sénatoriales sont
issus des municipales de 2014 et pas
d'élu en marche en 2014 le corps
électoral était plutôt à droite le corps
électoral que le corps électoral et à
droite nous nous allons perdre des
sièges lors aussi j'espère qu'il a droit
devant gagner le moins possible j'espère
la droite continuera à être majoritaire
au sénat c'est évident quelqu'un qui
voudrait dire linverse ce serait une
langue de bois absolument à gruissan il
y aura 2
vos élus la république en marche sans
aucun doute j'ai demandé autant j'ai
entendu des schistes ont déjà entendu
des chiffres ont déjà une aura 50 ou
soit pas donné les noms dans la vie on
aura deux fois moins donner un nouveau
pronostic mais c'est pas un pronostic
c'est une analyse sorti groggy les
sentiments et à gauche au ps
ab nous on va en perdre évidemment on en
a perdu 20 ou 25 lors des dernières
élections là ne les élections
municipales nous sont défavorables on va
peut-être en perdre le même nombre le
moins possible je sais pas combien
l'accès c'est aujourd'hui que vous posez
de lewy mais tout le monde dit la même
chose on sait que des départements qui
ne bougeront pas et les départements on
risque de baisser je vais pas vous
raconter des histoires dans l'élection
disent on va la gagner
on ne va pas la gagner cette élection
est la droite va la gagner et la droite
sera majoritaire au sénat
raison de plus pour renforcer le groupe
socialiste et pour faire venir au sénat
pour faire élire des sénateurs de gauche
qui pour en faire ce contrepoids à la
droite qui de toute façon sera
majoritaire de gauche c'est à dire ceux
qui sont favorables à radio quand nous
les socialistes le socialisme est de
gauche mais vous et moi et bien vu
qu'ils étaient socialistes qui est
maintenant décidé aussi de travailler qu
emmanuel macron donc on veut c'est là où
on pouvait très bien comment dans votre
groupe aujourd'hui mais non non il ya
crié aujourd'hui l'implosion du groupe
avec peut-être une destination haut
marche non vers le groupe blanc le
groupe a marché constituée qu'avec des
socialistes mise à part de deux
sénateurs je crois donc les socialistes
qui voulait aller au groupe en marche
ils sont maintenant et après les
ailleurs dans ce groupe en marche y en a
les deux tiers qui ne se représente pas
donc il va falloir déjà qu'ils
reconstituent leur douleur leur groupe
avant avant de progresser et puis les
socialistes qui vont être élus
socialistes n'y aura pas d'un président
du groupe socialiste non parce que il ya
des listes en marche donc
et les gens qui sont sur la liste en
marche se présenteront y adhérer au
groupe il y aura toujours vous à la tête
du groupe abba ça nous verrons bien
gênant les candidats avec eux je ne sais
pas si je serai candidat nous verrons
bien si on attend le les élections qu'on
nous le dira encore mais non mais enfin
je veux dire aujourd'hui je vais pas
vous raconter je suis candidat ou je ne
suis pas qu'un je ne sais pas si je
serai candidat à la présidence du groupe
bruno retailleau lui va quitter la
présence des pays de la loire il va
rester au sénat c'est ce qu'annonce
ouest france on le savait on s'en
doutait comment est ce que vous les
appréciez cette annonce moi j'ai pas
apprécié je dis simplement il s'est
passé la même chose pour christian
estrosi
je pense qu'il faut faire attention dû
jouer au bonneteau électorale et que
lorsque lorsqu'on se présente à la
présidence d'une région
en principe c'est pour six ans c'est pas
pour y rester ou pas y rester en
fonction des élections mais moi j'ai du
respect pour bruno retailleau qui vient
coller que je connais bien mais vous
devez pas un homme oui parce que je
parle par rapport aux gens si on veut
réhabiliter la politique c'est pas une
fois qu'on est sur un poste on doit on
doit y rester mais si je comprends
qu'ils fassent le choix du national par
rapport aux régionales il a été
directeur de campagne de jean gagnant de
françois fillon il est il incarne cette
ligne politique peut-être sera-t-il
candidat à la présidence des
républicains nous le rend bien
vous parliez tout à l'heure de votre
choix personnel est ce que vous serez
candidat ou pas la tête du groupe est ce
que vous estimez que gérard larcher lui
sera toujours le président du sénat le
25 ans le 1er octobre prochain dans son
élection
je crois qu'il n'y aura pas de surprise
je vous soutiendrai a bien envoyé voté
pour moi non mais ça lorsqu'on est dans
l'opposition votent pas pour le candidat
de la majorité à la présidence du groupe
ne crois pas que ce soit déjà vraiment
arriver là sur un vote symbolique les
groupes vote vote en groupe on ne votera
pas pour gérard larcher
moi j'ai rien contre larcher c'est un
bon président il restera présent et 6
ont vibré et son bilan est bon il soit
réélu président du sénat sans aucun sans
aucun problème et henry blessé des
tentatives diverses et variées pas qu'il
est jeune âge je ne sais pas trop
candidats à la république en marche un
candidat
gérard larcher président sortant vous
faites quoi moi je vote pour un candidat
socialiste
oui bien sûr tous les candidats au sénat
mais je n'en sais rien j'étais candidat
la dernière fois ça dépend de ce que
font les groupes soient chaque groupe
présente au premier tour sont qu'un
annuaire pour dire voilà on marque le
terrain on pèse en pestant soit pas de
toute façon est de vous envoyer deux
candidats nouvelle fois la pénalité ça
et c'était pas si je serai président du
groupe donc je ne sais pas si je peux
pas répondre à cette question ce que je
pense pour répondre clairement mais
encore sans aucune donc de bois gérard
la rue de l'arche est à mon sens sera
président du sénat le 2 octobre
alors allez-y aviez guillaume puisque
effectivement vous nous annoncez que le
groupe ait l'air va pouvoir pavoiser au
sénat à la fin du mandat 0,20 si vous
n'avez y veillerons gagner des sièges
vous pouvez déjà félicité gérard larcher
pour cette future réélection pas du tout
mais attendez c'est non mais sérieux là
parce que sir et on veut les aider dans
ce sens là ça va faire un peu d'ironie
et vos téléspectateurs vont vont se
lasser
moi je veux parler sans langue de bois
sont pas de nouveaux mondes l'ancien
monde parce que tous ceux qui se
réclament de nouveaux mondes
beaucoup viennent de l'ancien mendiants
n'ont pas encore quitté totalement mais
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la politique
dans le débat politique
il faut dire appeler un chat un chat il
faut dire les choses vont poser une
question est ce que qui sera président
du sénat je vais pas vous dire je n'en
sais rien je vous réponds je vous dis je
pense que gérard larcher sera président
du sénat la prochaine fois parce que je
pense que la droite sera encore
majoritaire voilà alors je vais volonté
de réforme du sénat chambre encore plus
territoriale qu'est ce qu'elle l'est
aujourd'hui jambes des territoires
est-ce que ça va dans le sens aussi dans
le sens de l'histoire est ce que c'est
votre souhait alors là je ne partage pas
totalement cela je pense que nous avons
besoin de mener une réflexion sur la
constitution sur les institutions parce
qu'on voit bien il yal encore et a
laissé transporter ans
il ya deux deux lignes parallèles 1 qui
voudrait que l'on soit un peu comme les
allemand le bundesrat c'est à dire que
le sénat soit l'assemblée des
territoires
enfin au moment où on supprime le cumul
des mandats si c'est pour vous mettre
que des cumulards que les présidents de
région europe ça n'a pas de sens mais ça
peut se comprendre en disant on ne fait
que ce qui concerne les territoires
et puis l'autre ligne qui est plutôt la
mienne aujourd'hui nous verrons comment
est le débat c'est un bicamérisme rénové
c'est à dire qu' on ne peut pas voter
une loi qui on peut pas mettre un an et
demi pour voter une
ouah il faut aller beaucoup plus vite il
faut peut-être le sénat sur certains
textes soient plus souvent en premier en
première lecture ces sujets là nous
devons les avoir
lorsque les choses avanceront j'ai cru
comprendre ce matin dans la presse que
le gouvernement voulait dès 2018
présenter une loi réformant le mode de
scrutin et abaissant le nombre de
députés ils n'ont pas de nous reparler
du sénat est ce que c'est un oubli ou
est ce que il pense que ça sera en même
temps c'était cette occasion là que nous
devons avancer
moi j'ai fait une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle lors du congrès à
versailles
je pense qu'à partir du moment où le
président de la république décide de
venir une fois par an devant les
parlementaires réunis en congrès pour
leur parler
je pense qu'il est il n'est pas pensable
qu'il s'en aille et qu'après les
parlementaires parlent de devant le
vinoux devant le favori devant le promu
gouvernement bon donc il ya des
évolutions constatées avant dernière
question vous avez fait
tournez votre calculette des digues est
ce que le gouvernement qui vise en fait
dans ces élections sénatoriales obtenir
les trois cinquièmes des congrès ce
qu'il y parviendra mais je pense qu'il y
parviendra on va déjà posé la question
et je vais le rendu de façon un peu
durement je vais pas vous le faire avoue
michel gault sûr mais je pense que cette
question est idiote
excusez moi de le dire c'est ça que je
les patients qu'ils lui mais ça n'existe
pas on n'élit pas d'un sénateur en
disant est ce que vous allez faire
partie des 3 5èmes non mais ça n'existe
pas d'accord raconter ce que vous voulez
dans des lances puce bien drôme de
l'ordre du morbihan le sénateur qui va
être élu va pas s'engager dans les
électeurs à voter la constitution moi ce
que je pense au contraire dans une
réforme de la constitution en fonction
du projet en voie pour notre d'accord
c'est bien noté c'est toi je ne voudrais
plus la question bonsoir à tous à la
semaine prochaine un bon soir
[Musique]